Oh what's this ah this is London it's
wonderful Oh Lucy always dreamed of
coming to London
she saw this it would be like she were
finally here Oh Paddington
this is perfect I've had a brilliant
idea I'm going to get a job and buy that
book rod Lucy's birthday no window
cleaner are you quite sure you're ready
for the workplace Paddington Phoenix
Buchanan dad will never be quiet
I suppose you know who I oh yes you're a
very famous actor VIP celebrity or used
to be now you do dog food commercials
this pop-up book where on earth did you
find mr. Gruber's antique shop
hold it right there but I'm not the
thief mysterious things have been
happening all over town
we're rich again I may look like a
hardened criminal but I'm innocent we're
gonna need a foolproof plan
if anyone can recognize a criminal it's
awesome it's a master of disguise well
this is breaking and entering haven't
broken anything wouldn't take it any of
us needed help he looks for the good in
all of us
mom Marie
take a seat
[Music]
you